مسجد خالص للمسلمين هذا واقع يسعى المحتل
لتغييره
في فترات الاعياد اليهوديه بشكل خاص تزداد
وتيره اقتحامات الاقصاح
تضاعف خلال الايام الماضيه عدد مقتحميه من
المستوطنين والمتطرفين اليهود
بتسهيلات وحمايه من شرطه الاحتلال يجولون
في باحاته وفي ازقه البلده القديمه من
القدس المحتله
وبشكل يمس بحرمه الاقصى ويستفز مشاعر
المسلمين يتبعون صلواتهم وطقوسهم
التلموديه عند عتبات الاقصى بالرقص
والغناء
كذلك يفعلون منذ بدء عيد العرش اليهودي
الذي يستمر حتى يوم الجمعه المقبل
في المقابل يضيق على الفلسطينيين
قوات من شرطه الاحتلال المنتشره بكثافه في
باحات المسجد الاقصى وعند ابوابه تفرض
قيود المشدده على دخول المصلين اليه
وتحديدا الشبان منهم
ولن يكتمل المشهد دون الاعتداء على
المرابطات في محيط الاقصى واعتقال بعضهم
صحيح ان الجماعات الاستيطانيه وجماعات
الهيكل المزعوم المتطرفه تستغل العياده
الدينيه عند اليهود للمس بحرمه الاقصى غير
ان ما يحدث هو نهج رسمي لتل ابيب الساعيه
لفرض التقسيم الزماني والمكاني لقبله
المسلمين الاولى
اما تقسيم الزماني فيعني تخصيص اوقات
محدده لدخول المسلمين واخرى خاصه باليهود
من خلال اقتسام الساعات والايام طوال
العام
اذا تم ذلك فانه سيتوجب على المسلمين
افراغ المسجد الاقصى لساعات محدده يوميا
كي يصلي فيه اليهود ثلاثه صلوات في اليوم
وتسعى سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه الى
تخصيص الاقصى لليهود خلال اعيادهم التي
تصل الى 100 يوم مضافا اليها ايام السبت
اما تقسيم المكاني فالمقصود به اسرائيليا
تخصيص امكنه وزوايا من المسجد الاقصى لكل
من الطرفين وهنا تسعى حكومه الاحتلال
لاقطاع منطقتين من المسجد
هي اذا محاوله للاخلال بالوضع التاريخي
القائم ذاك الذي يقصر الصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى على المسلمين مع اتاحه فرصه زيارته
للسياح من غير المسلمين
في منحا مغاير تماما تمضي سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مستمحه اول مره للمستوطنين
بتنفيذ اقتحامات المسجد الاقصى عام 2003
اقتحامات يريدها وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي ان تتم على مدار الساعه مع
امكانيه اداء المقتحمين الصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى صحيفه
كشفت عن مطالبه اتمار بنك فير بذلك في
رساله وجهها لاعضاء يمينيين في الكنيست
قال وفقا للصحيفه انه يامر بشده في ان
يدعم وزراء الصهيونيه الدينيه مقترحه